the clark county school district one of
the largest in the country has just
unveiled a new equitable
grading policy it's the kind of policy
that i would have loved when i was in
school which is about the harshest
condemnation
imaginable the new system removes
non-academic measures as factors in
grading so those measures include
attendance participation
responsibility lateness none of that
matters anymore
in terms of the grades students know no
longer need to worry that their grade in
a class will suffer
just because they aren't actually going
to the class attendance was you know
considered a bare minimum requirement
when i went to school
now it has become a mere superficial
detail also all scores under 50
are abolished a child cannot get less
than 50
on an assignment even if they don't
actually do it don't do it at all and
they spot you 50
the word failing has been removed from
the school's vocabulary
now students earning a score you know
between 50 and 59 percent
will be classified as emergent
once again i wish i had thought of this
as a kid no dad i'm not failing math i'm
uh i'm
emerging the superintendent of the
district
jesus jarrah recently defended the new
policy saying that quote
our kids will graduate from this high
school ready for the workforce in
high-paying jobs
yes you know those high-paying jobs
where you don't need to show up
or do anything or put in the slightest
effort or actually
succeed in any of the tasks you're
assigned well at least we can hope that
these students upon entering the job
market
will be fired with similarly gentle
language listen i'm not firing you
i'm just saying your ass needs to emerge
through the exit and never come back
that's all this is of course
far from the only equitable quote
unquote grading policy to be unveiled
in the last couple of years it's the
direction that all school districts will
will eventually go
all of them of course attending class
is kind of a moot point anyway if there
is no class to physically attend in the
first place though
indeed biden's secretary of education
gave a press conference yesterday where
he was very open to the idea
of shutting down in-person learning once
again this year
let's uh listen to that is there
anything
metrics wise or numbers-wise
threshold-wise that you would look at
and say all right maybe in person is not
the best
answer right now even if the year gets
started or is it
in person no matter what we have the
mitigation tools you know
we know what works and yes we're looking
at the metrics and obviously in close
consultation with cdc and
local health directors because there are
many local factors that contribute to
whether or not a school
should be open now that was just a
longer way of saying
yes we will definitely be shutting the
schools down at some point at least
partially
that's how i read it that would be my
prediction anyway
and it's probably for the best actually
because as kids across the country
um are if they go to school going to be
forced to wear masks all day
in their classes every day another
school district and states a mass
mandate most recently in fact
our district right here in nashville has
been added to the list
all students and staff will be required
to wear masks all day everywhere
from the bus to the classroom now as
always with these
mask mandates the one thing that's
missing is any sort of
rational science and common sense based
reason for it instead we hear only from
the adults
that it makes them feel better and that
it seems like it's necessary to keep the
kids safe
though they offer absolutely no data to
support it at all
just to um illustrate that point here's
a quick news report from our local abc
affiliate
here in town and just listen to this and
you tell me do you hear anything like
you know a data point a reason let's
let's listen and find out
i feel a lot better sending my kid into
school and i think
you know there are a lot of parents
feeling that same way right now there
were some opposing parents but i think
there were a lot more supportive parents
and i was very happy to see that right
now my son can't get vaccinated but he
does have to go to school so i want to
do everything i can to keep him safe in
that
in that context city is open
citywide no city-wide mandate there is
no data
to support any of this right now there
is not no state
mandate mass mandate so why are we doing
this to our children
and our job is to make sure that we are
protecting our students
we cannot teach them if we cannot
protect them
and so i would like us to continue to
follow with the proven mitigation
strategies that
are available to us
masks will be available on a daily basis
for anyone who forgets to bring theirs
to school
the board will reassess this mask
requirement when all metro government
issued mass grant requirements
are ended well there was at least it was
an eight to one vote on the school board
and you heard from the one sane one i
think her name was fran
bush and she was the she was the only
one who was against it
the rest of it though what did you hear
i feel a lot better
but you know i feel better we want to
keep the kids safe
lots of feels and wants here as as usual
but
is the mask necessary in order to keep
kids safe from covet
a virus which poses very little risk to
them to begin with
is it psychologically and physically
healthy to have children wearing these
pieces of cloth
on their faces all day how many of the
kids even wear them correctly
how dirty do these things get by the end
of the day
what effect does that have on their
health do the health benefits
actually outweigh the risks these are
all questions
and by the way what does it do to
children
emotionally and developmentally to
deprive them of the basic ability
to see each other's faces
what does it do to children emotionally
and developmentally and psychologically
to make them feel like speaking of feels
make them feel like
everyone around them is sick
that the air itself is toxic
has anybody wondered about any of that
is there any data on it
do they care about the data if it does
exist
the answer to that question at least the
last question is no
the point is simply that the adults in
charge feel better when the kids cover
their faces all day
and that's what matters most to them now
of course
we can protest these kinds of measures
and we should we can object
just as we can object to the insane
equitable grading policies
or to crt in the schools or the gender
theory indoctrination
or any of the other radical left-wing
indoctrination that public school
children endure in every public school
in america without exception
we can object we should object we can
protest
we should we should protest but we're
left still
at bottom with a stark reality that when
we send our kids into the system
we have no actual control over anything
that happens
no actual control no hands-on control
the schools own your kids as long as
they are in that building and even when
they're not in the building
that anyway is how the schools see it
and they don't hide the fact
and for all intents and purposes they're
right
the system has your child for most of
his waking hours
the system is in charge of educating him
and thus shaping his worldview
and instilling him with a moral code
things which are inextricably linked
to the act of education that's another
important point
people that say well we need to separate
indoctrination and education i just want
my kids to be
educated i don't want them to be
indoctrinated that's impossible
the two are linked you cannot have
education without indoctrination
unless you're educating a computer
unless you're programming a computer
but when it comes to human to human
education
it is it always comes packaged with a
world view
always no it's not that i don't want my
kid to be indoctrinated
i don't want to meet well i don't want
him to be indoctrinated by them
i don't want him to be indoctrinated
into that
and what happens is that the system
eventually will have more influence over
your kids than you do
your kid will become what the system
makes him
there may be rare exceptions to that
rule but they are
very rare indeed all of these things
we're witnessing
right now from the masking to the
indoctrination and everything in between
is the system exercising its ownership
of the children sent into its care
the mask becomes in some ways the most
profound statement of ownership almost
like branding on a
on cattle and that probably is the best
analogy because that's how kids in the
system are treated they're like farm
animals
to be conformed into a herd and then
heard it along in whatever direction it
prefers
if your kid goes to public school then i
mean it's good to get involved as much
as possible and to show up at the school
board meetings
and to join the pta and do all that you
can do but this cannot be the ultimate
solution to
the problem of the public school system
because these are band-aid measures
this is you with a bucket on the beach
struggling against the tide
you can't stop it you can only hope to
interfere slightly
slightly is better than not at all but
it's not a solution
so what is the solution what's the
answer the answer is the one i always
give but not everybody wants to hear it
the solution to the public school system
in the end
is its abandonment and then its collapse
and its destruction
that's the solution as long as we are
determined to outsource our children's
formation to the state
as long as we have given it that immense
power
these problems will remain
there is never going to be a time
when you can actually trust the state to
educate your child
never it is too much power
it is too much power for any government
at any time
but especially this government at this
time
if we can improve anything at all in the
system it's only by degree
you can hope by getting involved to make
it slightly less
bad
but anything more than that will require
fundamental and drastic change
you know people say to me all the time
um well matt you you point out all these
problems
and what are the solutions you don't
give us any solutions we want solutions
well my answer to that is number one
there is value in pointing out the
problem
when much of the country doesn't see the
problem so we got to start with that
you know you got to drag the darkness
into the light you got to start there
and in some ways we haven't been able to
get past that as a culture yet
i mean we can't work to fix a problem
until everyone sees that it is one
and so right now we're at square one
just getting people to see that the
problem exists
but the other thing with solutions is
that when most people when they say i
don't want to hear all these problems i
want to hear solutions
they don't really want solutions do they
when they say solutions they mean okay
give me a five-step plan
that's easy to do and will require
almost no sacrifice on my part
that's what i want you know tell me to
write a letter to these people tell me
to hold a sign over here tell me to do
this to do that
and and then the problem will go away
you know we are way past that there
aren't
any all of the serious problems in our
culture out of all of them
none of them can be simply solved that
way
it requires drastic changes so when it
comes to the school system if you really
want to know the solution
it is to abandon it it is to starve it
to death
by pulling your kids out of it
but we can't do that we have to
drastically change our lifestyle
we we have to change everything yeah i
know it's not easy
but it's the solution there isn't
another one
it's the only one now we have to decide
do we really want to solve the problem
or not well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content